the British School Doha
where the World Cup has stopped classes
but the kids play on
chasing their own footballing dreams for
now it's the England whale showdown in
Qatar inspiring and exciting them I'm
feeling confident that England's gonna
win because Wales haven't been doing
very good in this world cup
I think England is going to be done 4-0
that result would end wales's journey in
Qatar after waiting 64 years to return
to the World Cup
there's still deep frustration amongst
the Welsh players that they held out
until the eighth minute of injury time
before going on to lose to Iran in the
last game now they have to be England
for the first time since 1984 and hope
the USA and Iran draw to progress in the
tournament
this current moment is we're not in the
in the greatest of positions and
obviously we haven't had an amazing
tournament but like I said this is
football it's not easy it's um it's
difficult so yeah we the main thing for
us all is we we've stuck together as a
group like we've always done and like
we'll fight again we'll go on the pitch
we'll give everything and I think our
supporters know that
you've seen our reaction when we
conceded against Iran how devastating we
all were lying on the floor heartbroken
after the game everybody was was upset
so
um no one can have a question our
commitment but um we'll all stick
together through thick and thin through
the ups and downs
there were many Downs for Generations
until Bale and Co former stars like Dean
Saunders never had the chance to
represent Wales in tournaments they're
not frightened of anyone we beat Ukraine
we beat Belgium you know we've had some
great results we've beat some big teams
so that group of players are together
they've got team spirit they've got the
country behind them you know everyone in
Wales is sitting in front of the TV
hoping we can beat England whether we
qualify or not they just want to be
England
would have to lose by four goals to be
knocked out their shortcomings were
exposed in Friday's goalless draw with
the Americans but playing your neighbor
adds extra motivation
well basically they're here and we're
right there
there's not a lot more I can say than
that really
foreign
yeah it's like any two countries who's
whose borders are next to each other
there's uh there's a competitive rivalry
Gareth southgate's big decision is
whether to freshen up the lineup
thinking about matches to come for Wales
manager Rob page everything rests on
this British Face-Off and avoiding
flying home this week Rob Harris Sky
News Doha